[Music]
thank you so much for being here I
really appreciate it especially coming
out to talk with such a ghastly title
but it's something that I think some
great importance and this is what I want
to talk with you about tonight is this
issue that I've been thinking a lot
about which is that repeatedly
throughout history groups of people have
inflicted violence on other members of
the population and they have inflicted
this violence in coordination with the
authorities and against groups of people
in their society that were no direct
threat to them and were defenseless and
so what's going on here how can we
understand the sort of thing this facet
of human behavior because it's of deep
importance for us to understand this if
we want to prevent it in the future so
of course we're familiar with the Nazis
and their killing of millions of people
based on religious and ethnic and
political events this is this here is
from the Nanking Massacre in 1937 when
the Japanese invaded China and killed
hundreds of thousands of unarmed
civilians in China and systematically
raped between 80 and a hundred thousand
people this is from 1915 this is the
systematic killing of the Armenian
population by the Ottoman Turks and in
it's estimated that between 1 and 1/2
million Armenians were killed during
this and then in in 1994 in the period
of a hundred days the Hutu in Rwanda
killed 800,000 Tutsi and this was
accomplished with machetes and at the
peak of this they were actually
achieving a higher killing rate with
machetes than the Nazis had accomplished
with gas chambers and so the question is
what's going on here
so historians you know this stuff is
well-documented historians point to
issues about political and civil strife
and economic troubles
but the real issue is that the only way
these events can happen is when there's
a distinct change in the behavior of
individuals and how can we understand
that change in behavior so what I want
to tell you about tonight is the science
of what we understand about that and I
want to put together a new framework to
see how we can understand this sort of
thing and end by saying what we can do
about it so let's start at the very
beginning so it turns out what we think
about human evolution the story that we
all know about Darwinian evolution is
that it's survival of the fittest right
so you have to be a really good
competitor in order to be able to
survive and do well and the that's a
pretty good story but people started
realizing there was a little bit of a
problem with the issue of altruism how
does that explain why people help each
other out that's not taken care of in
there just by thinking about individual
selection and that got people thinking
about kin selection so it turns out that
there's this notion of The Selfish Gene
and if I share some genetic materials my
brother or with my cousin's and so on
then maybe that explains why I want to
help them out that's known as kin
selection in fact the evolutionary
biologist J s Haldane once said I would
gladly jump in a river to save two of my
brothers or eight of my cousins and so
it turns out that's the way that
biologists think about kids like you but
it turns out even that's not enough to
explain things because in fact people
get together and they cooperate
irrespective of kinship and that led
people to this idea about group
selection which is to say if you are the
kind of person who cooperates with other
people then as a group you all get
selected up as a group you do better
than people over here who aren't very
cooperative with their neighbors and so
there's been many books on this these
are just three books in the past year on
this issue of group selection and the
term for this is eusociality
u meaning good or positive so it's this
positive social thing where you get this
glue irrespective
ship that allows you to build tribes and
groups and Nations
okay so so the author Jonathan hate gave
a nice analogy for this he said as a
result of this evolutionary history when
you think about humans we're sort of 90
percent primates meaning we're all about
the individual competition and we're ten
percent honeybee and by honeybee he
means you know sometimes we all come
together for the good of the hive and
that's the kind of thing that can't be
explained just by individual selection
but instead it really is this issue of
selecting for whole groups that makes us
want to work with one another now one of
the costs of this is that you get in
groups and out groups so let me just
concentrate on the in-group part of this
for a minute so what happens within
groups is you get people saying okay
look we're gonna cooperate with one
another and we get to enjoy all the
benefits of that we get to cooperate and
work together and everybody benefits as
a result of that and it turns out it's
not just humans there was a very recent
study that showed that you even see this
in for example rhesus monkeys they have
in-groups and out-groups and this is on
an island in Puerto Rico and what you
can do is take pictures of all the
monkeys and then you show the monkeys
pictures of the other monkeys and just
by the way that they look and they react
you can measure who's in their in-group
and out-group of their monkey troop and
this even works with monkeys who just
switched troops so two weeks ago these
guys were their in-group now it's their
out-group and you can see the change in
their reaction so it's fast and
dynamically updating all the time and it
shows that monkeys really care about
who's in their in-group and who's in
their out-group and of course there's
this issue of religion too and I know
that sometimes the neo atheists will
talk about religion as being like a a
pathological virus and and that's
actually not the right way to think
about it from an evolutionary point of
view things are judged by what they
cause people to do and what religions
cause is for people to group together to
be you social so so what happens with
religions is you define a group you
coordinate the behavior of the group and
and you incentivize the group to
cooperate
and work together so as you know as one
evolutionary biologist in the late
18-hundreds said religion is just it's
just another weapon in the Darwinian
struggle for survival in other words if
it were maladaptive it would have gone
away but it's actually it is adaptive
because it causes groups to come
together and work together okay so what
does all this have to do with the brain
well it turns out that historically
traditionally we've always studied the
brain by looking at individual bits and
pieces of it so you say okay well this
is how vision works and this is how
hearing works so there's how
decision-making works and so on and it's
only in recent years the people who are
going to appreciate that in fact a lot
of the brain circuitry has to do with
this eusociality a lot of it has to do
with how you interact with other brains
trust and reputation and allegiances and
this has led to a new field called
social neuroscience which studies this
sort of thing and that's what I'm going
to tell you about tonight and what that
tells us about group behavior
[Music]